- If Elon Musk is in the news
it's usually for one of three reasons:
he's announcing a Tesla product
that will never materialize,
he's revealing the
existence of another child,
or he's pretending to buy a
company and then backing out.
Well, Tesla doesn't have any new products,
he's up to 10 kids that we know of,
so Elon Musk now wants to back out
of his purchase of Twitter.
Although some headlines said,
"Musk cancels Twitter deal,"
that's not quite accurate.
Musk has informed Twitter that he believes
that the company is in breach
of the acquisition agreement
and that he therefore will no
longer perform the contract
by purchasing the company.
Twitter, on the other
hand, says that it will sue
to force Musk to buy the company
at the original sales price.
So this raises all sorts of questions.
Can Elon get out of the
deal because of bots?
Can Musk pay $1 billion
to cancel the contract?
And if Twitter sues, can a
judge force Musk to go through
with this multi-billion dollar deal?
(upbeat music)
So how did Elon Musk find
himself in this situation?
Well, Musk is an
avid-slash-obsessed Twitter user.
In early 2022, Musk
initiated conversations
with Twitter bigwigs and
started buying Twitter stock.
In February and March, Musk
accumulated over 9% ownership
of Twitter's common shares
without formally disclosing his interest
in a potential purchase, which
was a violation of SEC rules.
The SEC mandates that anyone who acquires
more than 5% of the
company's common shares
has to disclose those holdings
within 10 calendar days.
Musk finally signed his filing
21 days after March 14th,
the date his stake surpassed 5%.
Now after accepting and
then rejecting a seat
on Twitter's board of directors,
Elon Musk made an offer to
purchase Twitter for $44 billion.
After a bunch of back and
forth, Twitter agreed to sell
if Musk could come up with the financing,
eventually settling on a
purchase price at $54.20 a share,
which is entirely possible
to be a 4/20 joke.
Now for reasons I won't go into,
Musk styled the deal as a merger
with a specially created company,
so if you hear the term merger agreement
you can just think of purchase agreement.
And on April 25th,
Twitter and Musk announced
a joint agreement.
Quote, "Free speech is the bedrock
"of a functioning democracy,
"and Twitter is the digital town square
"where matters vital to the
future of humanity are debated."
Musk also said, quote, "I also
want to make Twitter better
"than ever by enhancing the
product with new features,
"making the algorithms open
source to increase trust,
"defeating the spam bots, and
authenticating all humans."
But on May 15th, Musk
started trying to backtrack
on the deal.
He tweeted that he was
putting the deal on hold
because he believed that more
than 5% of Twitter's user base
was made up of bots.
A bot in this context
means an automated account
that isn't linked to a real person.
Now Twitter gave Musk more
information about bots,
but on July 8th, Musk told the SEC
that he was exercising his
right to terminate the contract.
Twitter fired back that it will sue Musk
to have him buy the company.
So can Musk end the contract,
or can Twitter sue him for damages?
Well, everything hinges on
the contractual language
that Musk says gives him the
right to terminate the deal.
So let's look at the letter
that Musk sent to the SEC
claiming to back out of the deal,
and let's look at the contract provisions
to see what rights are afforded.
Now mergers and acquisitions
transactions often involve
the disclosure or
transfer of personal data
from a seller to a purchaser.
This may include all data
about the target company
and its assets like data about employees,
customers, users, and contractors.
Now one point of clarification here,
this is not due diligence.
Due diligence is something you do
before you enter into a merger
or acquisition agreement.
But in this case Musk didn't
do very much due diligence.
He signed the merger agreement
without having access
to much inside information from Twitter.
Here Musk says that he is
terminating the contract
because Twitter violated its obligations
to provide him with access to information
that is required under the contract.
But crucially, this is not information
for due diligence purposes.
The time for due diligence is long over.
It was over the second
that Elon Musk signed
the merger agreement.
But at any rate, section
6.4 of the merger contract
is entitled Access to
Information and Confidentiality.
This is the clause that
Musk says Twitter breached,
which states, quote,
"Upon reasonable notice,
"the company shall and shall
cause each of its subsidiaries
"to afford to the
representatives of parent's
"reasonable access at parent's
sole costs and expense
"in a manner not disruptive
in any material respect
"to the operations of the business
"of the company and its subsidiaries
"to the properties, books,
and records of the company
"and its subsidiaries,
"and shall cause each of its subsidiaries
"to furnish promptly two representatives
"all information concerning
the business, properties,
"and personnel of the
company and its subsidiaries
"as may reasonably be requested
in writing, in each case,
"for any reasonable business purpose
"related to the consummation
of the transactions
"contemplated by this agreement."
Now that is lawyer speak for,
"Twitter must provide Musk
with company information."
And there are all sorts of caveats.
It must be related to a business purpose.
Query whether Musk's requests are related
to a business purpose or
to screw over the business,
it's hard to say.
But Musk's legal team
has said that, quote,
"Twitter has not complied with
its contractual obligations
"under section 6.4."
Quote, "For nearly two months,
"Mr. Musk has sought the
data information necessary
"to make an independent assessment
of the prevalence of fake
"or spam accounts on Twitter's platform.
"This information is fundamental
to Twitter's business
"and financial performance
and is necessary
"to consummate the
transactions contemplated
"by the merger agreement
because it is needed to ensure
"Twitter's satisfaction of
the conditions to closing,
"to facilitate Mr. Musk's
financing and financial planning
"for the transaction,
"and to engage in transaction
planning for the business."
So according to Musk's lawyers,
Twitter breached its
contractual obligations
to close the deal.
The centerpiece of the letter
is that Twitter misrepresented
the number of bots and refused
to give Musk information
that would identify the true
number of bots on the platform.
Though the lawyers
couched it very carefully.
Quote, "Preliminary analysis
by Mr. Musk's advisors
"of the information
provided by Twitter to date
"causes Mr. Musk to strongly believe
"that the proportion of
false and spam accounts
"included in the reported MDAU count
"is wildly higher than 5%."
Now that is not a factual
claim about anything
except what Elon Musk personally believes,
which is a very sneaky way
of avoiding an actual factual claim
that could subject the lawyers
to a little bit more scrutiny
and Musk in general to more liability.
But let's hear about it
from the man himself.
Elon went on a podcast to explain
that Twitter has so many bots
that it makes Twitter a
totally different company
than the one he thought he was buying.
Quote-
- You know,
if they in fact have been firstly claiming
less than 5% of fake or spam accounts,
but in fact it is four or
five times that number,
or perhaps 10 times that
number, this is a big deal.
It's sort of like if you said, "Okay,
"I agree to buy your house."
You say the house has
less than 5% termites.
That's an acceptable number.
But if it turns out it is 90%
termites, that's not okay.
You know, it's not the same house.
- Now if Twitter is 90% bots,
then Elon Musk might be correct
for reasons that we'll
discuss in a moment.
But is Twitter 90% bots? Probably not.
But let's talk about
Twitter's obligations.
Twitter responded to Musk
by giving him information
about how it estimates the
number of fake accounts.
There's a long Twitter
thread by the Twitter CEO
that explains where the
calculations came from.
He said the 5% estimate
is based on, quote,
"Multiple human reviews in replicate
"of thousands of accounts
that are sampled at random
"consistently over time from
accounts we count as MDAUs."
Now Twitter claims that
it's human review process
uses both public and private
data like IP addresses,
geolocation, and other factors
to make a determination
about whether an account
belongs to a real person.
Musk infamously responded to this thread
with a simple poop emoji
because that is the level of
discourse that we face here.
But Twitter eventually
caved to Musk's demand
for more information by
giving him information
about every single tweet
in the Twitter universe.
This has been referred
to as the Firehose API,
a stream of every tweet that's been sent.
This dataset includes
records of user tweets,
the devices those users tweeted from,
and real time API data.
And despite receiving this information,
Musk says that he couldn't perform
the analysis he wanted to,
which may not be Twitter's problem,
but his lawyers identified
five more categories of stuff
that they wanted related to user accounts.
But the bottom line here is
that Twitter probably gave Musk
all the data he could
reasonably be entitled to,
and the contract probably
doesn't require more of that.
But there is another wrinkle
here that deserves discussion
because even if Twitter
underestimated the number of bots
on the platform, Musk still
doesn't have the legal right
to cancel the agreement because
not all misrepresentations
give Musk the right to back out.
Now in a normal contract
a material misrepresentation
could absolutely give rise
to canceling or terminating a contract,
but this is a different kind of contract
because people don't like to enter
into these merger agreements
and then have the
possibility of backing out.
And this contract would only be breached
if the misrepresentations had a, quote,
"Material adverse effect."
Now the phrase material
adverse effect is a term of art
used in mergers and acquisitions law.
It's usually defined in the contract
in a very long paragraph.
And here the language has been interpreted
several times by Delaware Courts.
We'll talk more about
why Delaware later on,
because that's the whole
thing in and of itself.
But in Delaware there is a high standard
for showing a material adverse effect.
The burden of proof is
usually on the buyer.
Usually material adverse effect is invoked
when the target company starts having
significant performance problems.
But even if a company's
performance is in decline
and it's dramatic, Delaware
Courts generally say
that the time period needs
to be measured in years,
not just a few bad months.
And as far as I can tell,
Delaware Courts had never found
a misrepresentation to give rise
to a material adverse effect
until 2018 in the case called
Akorn v. Fresenius Kabi AG.
The Delaware Courts summarized
the buyer's burden of proof.
Quote, "A buyer faces a heavy burden
"when it attempts to invoke a
material adverse effect clause
"in order to avoid its
obligations to close.
"A short-term hiccup in
earnings should not suffice;
"rather than material adverse
effects should be material
"when viewed from the
longer-term perspective
"of a reasonable acquirer.
"In the absence of
evidence to the contrary,
"a corporate acquirer may be assumed
"to be purchasing the target
"as part of a long-term strategy.
"The important consideration therefore
"is whether there has
been an adverse change
"in the target's business
that is consequential
"to the company's long-term earnings power
"over a commercially reasonable period,
"which one would expect
to be measured in years
"rather than months."
The buyer in Akorn was able to demonstrate
that the magnitude of the change
in performance was material
and this poor performance
lasted for over a year.
This precedent probably isn't
very helpful to Musk's claim
that spam accounts mean that Twitter
is dramatically overstating
its performance in ways
that could impact Twitter's
profitability down the line.
In fact, one could argue
that if there are more bots
than they know of,
then its profitability can
only go up even further
'cause he'll get rid of the bots
and make it even more profitable per user.
And this is especially
true since Musk said
he wanted to acquire Twitter
to improve the product
by eliminating the bots.
The SEC filings include voicemails by Musk
where he presses Twitter to
get the deal done quickly
so he can fix the spam accounts
and make the company more profitable.
Musk then sent a voice
message saying, quote,
"If the deal doesn't work,
"given that I don't have
confidence in management
"nor do I believe I can
drive the necessary change
"in the public market,
"I would need to reconsider
my position as a shareholder.
"This is not a threat, it's
simply not a good investment
"without the changes
that need to be made."
So even though Musk was at the time
the company's top shareholder,
he didn't think the stock
was a good investment
unless changes were made.
He then offered Twitter a share price
that was significantly above its value.
In other words, Elon Musk
made it clear from the outset
that his interest in
Twitter had nothing to do
with its current profitability.
And he knew that there were too many bots.
He said he wanted to buy
Twitter to prove a point
about free speech,
and he said he wanted
to make a better product
by authenticating users, eliminating spam,
and adding an edit button.
So to sum it up,
it looks like Twitter has
a pretty good argument
that they gave Musk all the
information that he needed
and was entitled to.
And further, Twitter can
certainly argue that, number one,
the bot numbers aren't
wrong, but even if they were,
it's still not a material adverse effect.
If the bot numbers are 7% instead of five,
that's probably not material.
Though it's also probably
important to know
that one reason that Musk and
his lawyers have couched this
as a failure to provide info
instead of focusing on
claims of misrepresentation
is that the misrepresentations are covered
by the material adverse effect standard,
whereas the obligations of the company
found in the covenants are
generally considered material.
So if they breached their
obligations on the covenants,
they have a better chance of
getting out of the deal itself.
Additionally, Musk's lawyers also claim
that Twitter failed to run their business
in the ordinary course of business
by firing two key
employees and losing others
in violation of section 6.1
of the merger agreement.
That section of the
contract requires Twitter
to seek and obtain
consent before deviating
from its obligations
to conduct its business
in the ordinary course and
preserve substantially intact
the material components
of its current business organization.
And this is a very common term you see
in these kinds of agreements.
The reason is obvious.
When you're buying a company
you want to make sure that,
that company continues
in more or less the same
vein than it started
and it doesn't completely
change their business
while you're in the process of buying it.
And here Twitter fired
its revenue product lead
and the general manager of consumer
and other employees to it,
possibly because Elon Musk
was buying the company.
So Musk said that he
objected to Twitter firing
many talent acquisition employees
and that he doesn't like
Twitter's hiring freeze.
Quote, "The company has not
received parent's consent
"for changes in the
conduct of its business,
"including for the specific
changes listed above."
The company's actions therefore
constitute a material breach
of section 6.1 of the merger agreement.
Now it is very rare
for deals to fall apart
over these kinds of obligations.
Number one, Twitter legally
can't force anyone to stay,
not since the 13th Amendment was passed.
And additionally, sometimes as a company
you need to be able to terminate people.
That happens in the
regular course of business.
So we'll see if there's any hay
here, but it seems unlikely.
So let's talk about what's going to happen
in the ensuing litigation.
Nothing is certain in litigation,
but based on the facts of this case
in terms of the legal arguments
I'd much rather be Twitter than Elon
in this particular situation.
Now normally when you're talking
about a breach of contract
and contract damages,
you're talking about expectation damages.
The party that didn't
breach is entitled to be
where they expected to be
after the contract was consummated,
and you measure that by
taking, in this case,
the promised price,
subtracting the current
price of the company,
and the delta is the amount
that would be necessary
to compensate you for
where you expected to be.
But here the parties negotiated
a bilateral $1 billion
termination penalty.
They considered that Twitter
might get a better offer
and might want to cancel this deal
so they could go with the better offer.
And they also considered that
Musk might just, you know,
Musk everything up.
But here this termination
provision is functioning
like a liquidated damages provision.
It sets the damages at $1 billion.
Now I suspect that if Elon
Musk could get out of this deal
by just paying 1$
billion and walking away,
he would probably take that
deal and just walk away.
But here's where things
get really, really sticky
because section 9.9B
of the merger agreement
gives Twitter the right to sue Musk
for specific performance.
Now that is a legal term of art,
but that basically means
that Twitter can sue Musk
and it can seek an
injunction from the court
forcing Musk to close the deal.
Now that is particularly complicated here
because we are talking about a deal
worth tens of billions of dollars.
And it's also complicated
because the deal requires
outside financing from several banks.
But the way that those
agreements are written,
the banks don't have a
whole lot of outs here.
Now in law school they teach students
that specific performance
is very rare, and it is.
Courts generally aren't in
the habit of forcing you
to do something that you don't want.
See, for example, the 13th Amendment.
But it most often happens with real estate
because it's thought
that, at least legally,
each piece of real
estate is a unique thing
that can't be compensated purely by money.
But when you're dealing with contracts,
courts would much rather
make people pay money
and go their separate ways.
However, it happens more frequently
in a context of mergers and acquisitions.
Delaware Courts have been known
to order specific performance
in just such a situation as this.
Although it's more common for buyers
to try and force specific performance,
Delaware Courts agree that
sellers in the M&A context
also have the right to force
the sale to completion.
So this is what happened
when a company called IBP,
the nation's top beef distributor,
entered into a merger
agreement with Tyson Foods,
the nation's leading chicken distributor.
Both companies performed poorly
after the merger agreement was announced
and Tyson's had buyer's remorse.
It tried to terminate the agreement,
but IBP sued for specific performance.
And in addressing whether a
seller has the right to sue
for specific performance,
the court found no, quote,
"Compelling reason why sellers in mergers
"and acquisitions transactions
should have less of a right
"to demand specific
performance than buyers."
So the court concluded that
Tyson had to go through
with the purchase.
The court said that even
figuring out the right measure
of cash damages would be too hard
since the amount was presumably huge.
The court said that specific
performance was doable
since during trial Tyson's admitted
that it just wanted a lower price
and that the acquisition
was still a good strategy
for the company.
The court also said that the shareholders
would be better served on the whole
by a specific performance remedy
rather than a large damages award
that did nothing but cost
Tyson a large amount of money.
And now I need to explain some trivia
about the Delaware Courts of Chancery
where this case is going to end up.
If you've been paying
attention to litigation,
you often hear people say
it'll take years to resolve anything,
and that's usually the case.
That is not the case in the
Delaware Chancery Courts.
The Delaware Chancery Courts are basically
business courts on steroids.
They handle mergers and
acquisitions for breakfast,
and Delaware made a name for itself
by being the most business-friendly
state in the country.
And the Delaware Chancery
Courts have a specific expertise
in dealing with these
enormous business disputes.
And they are fast.
This could end up being resolved in months
rather than years.
And while the numbers are very high,
the dollar amounts are very high,
this is not a particularly complex case.
In fact, Elon Musk is incredibly online,
so, so many of these statements
that he has made are public
and will absolutely be used against him.
So we'll probably have an answer
to this question pretty quickly.
And at base, the litigation
outcomes are pretty stark:
$1 billion in damages or
force Musk to pay $44 billion
to acquire a company he doesn't want.
Now in reality, depending
on how litigation goes,
I'm sure all of the parties
will probably negotiate
something in between.
Maybe a bigger fee that
lets Elon walk away
or maybe a lower price and
he consummates the deal.
It's entirely possible that
everything was just posturing
for him to get a better
deal in the long term.
Or maybe Elon never wanted
Twitter in the first place.
Who knows?
But the important thing is that lawyers
are going to get paid.
And speaking of which,
there is the breaking news
that Twitter has indeed sued Elon Musk
for one count of breach of contract.
The company asked the
Delaware Court of Chancery
to enjoin Musk from further
breaches of contract,
to compel him to fulfill
his legal obligations,
and to compel consummation of the merger
upon satisfaction of a few of
the outstanding conditions.
Now maybe it's just me, but I
find this particular complaint
to be a pretty hilarious document.
You can effectively put whatever
you want into a complaint.
It's your opportunity to
tell your side of the story,
and Twitter is doing just that,
but it also just savages Elon
Musk using his own statements
and fills in quite a bit of the story.
And it covers exactly
what you would expect,
that Musk is in material
breach of the merger agreement.
Twitter alleges that Musk
didn't uphold his obligations,
including financing, public
disparagement of the company,
and misuses information
in the whole, you know,
backing out of the deal thing.
But it also includes interesting tidbits
like Musk didn't even read
the information and reports
that Twitter gave him, even
though he's complaining
about not having enough information.
And Twitter alleges that
he can't avail himself
of the $1 billion termination fee
and must specifically perform.
He must consummate the
deal for $44 billion.
But given that this is Elon Musk,
this is only the beginning
of the craziness.
And you'll be able to read
all about the future antics
in today's sponsor, Morning Brew,
because that is my
favorite way to catch up
with pop culture and the news.
I've actually been subscribed
to Morning Brew for forever.
It's one of my absolute
favorite newsletters,
and I'm thrilled to tell you why,
because if you didn't know Morning Brew
is a daily newsletter delivered
Monday through Sunday.
It gets you up to speed on
business, finance, tech, and law
in just five minutes,
and it provides a fantastic quick survey
of the most important issues
while being witty,
irreverent, and informative.
It's really, really funny.
And did I mention it's completely free?
This week I learned all about
the James Webb Space Telescope,
the continuing destruction
of my stock portfolio,
and the continuing destruction
of the Texas power grid
which apparently doesn't
work in the winter
or in the summer now.
Morning Brew is basically
exactly the mix of news
that I'm actually interested in
and stuff I didn't even know
that I wanted to know about,
and it's all written in a hilarious style.
Morning Brew is one of the few emails
that I actually open every single day.
So LegalEagles, this one
is a complete no-brainer.
Morning Brew is completely free
and it takes less than
15 seconds to subscribe.
Just click on the link
that's on screen right now
or in the description to
get Morning Brew for free.
And not only will you get a newsletter
that you'll actually read,
you'll actually help out this channel too.
So click on the link below to
get Morning Brew right away.
And after you sign up you
should click on this playlist
for more LegalEagle, or
I'll see you in court.